good morning members
good morning members of the public
you're all very welcome this morning to
baby district council's planning
committee meeting of the 16th of
december
first of all may i remind you of some of
the domestic
arrangements please ensure that the
cameras
and microphones are turned off when not
in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you wish to speak a point of
order
declare and or interest or requesting an
adjournment
please use the hands up function on the
taskbar
members you are reminded that that
members are reminded that they should
not
have alternative communication lines
open
such as other teams chats and that if
you are contacted by a third party
during the application you should bring
this to the legal advisors attention
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
if members do lose connection
to the meeting that they are that they
must contact the member support officer
mandy smith as soon as possible
we'll be using modern gov to conduct all
electronic votes
during this meeting would like to remind
everyone present that this meeting will
be broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated film
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where they are
confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are
also consenting to being recorded by the
council
and to the possible use of those selling
recordings for webcast
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
i'd now like to introduce the officers
we've got mark russell
the acton-planning area plan and manager
rose walton who's the case offer officer
indie praise
the planning lawyer and robert
carmichael the governance officer
i will now move to the agenda and
item number one is apologies for absence
and substitutions
uh robert thank you chair
so this morning we have apologies from
councillor plum
and councillor alistair mccraw is
substituting for him
and i can confirm through modern.gov
that everyone is here
thank you so we've all signed in well
done
um and right
item number two declarations of
interests
are there any to declare yes mr chairman
uh councillor kensington yep um
i declare personal interest in that my
son's property backs onto the site
it's whether that's the properties on
lady lane that
yeah lady lane that back onto the site
i will take part in the debate but not
vote right
um over to the lawyer
um okay well councillor hinson has
declared it as a personal interest
obviously it's not his
um peculiar interest so he's he's
expressed
an intention of not voting which i
understand
um i'll just make sure mr carmichael and
i have one mind of that
if i may i think yeah yeah you better
check that out
are you there robert yes sorry sorry and
i was just thinking um
yeah i can't see a reason not to do that
no
it's not a pecuniary interest because
it's not councillor hinton or
or his or her or his the rule is it's
yourself or your wife or partner isn't
it not family doesn't extend to family
members and if
counselor hinton's explain the nature of
the personal interest and says he
intends to
uh deal with it by not voting which i
think is fair enough
yes i would just add only that as it's
not a peculiar interest that as
councillor hinton has made it clear that
he will not be voting that wouldn't be
any different from
any other time that a council would
choose not to vote on an application
so there's i don't see any issue
indeed and he's made it very clear right
at the start so i think it's all quite
acceptable
um okay then councillor hinton we've
noted that
and you've got the all clear to speak
and you've decided not to vote so thank
you very much
so no other um decorations of interest
from anybody
no thank you very much right item three
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 18th of november now i don't
believe we can do that
um robert
thank you chair um so there was a um
a request from mr russell area planning
manager to
withdraw the minutes for a further
review of them
um i don't know if mr russell wants to
comment more but they won't be heard
today
um so apologies for that chair that they
were put before that they couldn't but
alex let mark explain further thank
you sorry chair that was an oversight on
our part i just needed to check one of
the references to a policy and
rather than rushing it and getting it
wrong i decided it was better to
postpone it until the next meeting so my
apologies to that to members for the
delay on that okay so that will come to
us in january then
thank you very much then we'll move on
to uh item
number four which is um
i know i think there's just bear with me
yeah yes that's better it's um
notifications and petitions done
received yeah
thank you very much and then item five
um
which is members um site inspections or
offices are the officers are there any
site inspection requests i have to ask
you that
there there have been chair but you'll
be aware of the ongoing rules on that
yep thank you very much and there's none
from members
because no hands have gone up no
thank you very much so we'll move on
there's no site inspection requests
so we're now on to item six
which is the plan and application for
determination by the committee
um right and that is on
page 11.
and i'll ask rose walton the case
officer
to take us through it over to you thank
you
thank you chair i'm just loading the
presentation up now
and if somebody would be able to confirm
when they're able to
actually page 17 members
[Music]
okay great um thank you uh good morning
chair good morning members
the application we have today is for the
erection of 15 dwellings
with associated garages and parking
the creation of a vehicular access
and the provision of open space which
would all follow the demolition of an
existing dwelling on the site
the site is within hadley which is
identified as
a town in urban area within the adopted
core strategy cs2
which states that most new development
will be directed to these areas
sorry sorry rose i don't know if it's
going through the slides
it's still showing the first slide
that's what i'm getting anyways yes
i'm sorry my internet's not great so it
is a bit delayed
if you could let me know when it's moved
on to the second slide
well it's not done anything at the
moment it's also
showing with the side panel of the each
of the slides so
we should just see the current slide
rather than the
yes it's going to slow you through yeah
um bear with me just a second and i'll
bring it up
in presentation mode
oh yes we're back to number slide one
slowly two is headley
okay bullet and to slide through is that
showing you okay
okay great thank you melanie that solved
the problem
uh i have identified the key planning
issues
as accordance with policy design and
layout
residential amenity parking and highway
safety
and ecology
in terms of policy the site located
here um
is within the built up area boundary of
hadley shown in
orange around the edge here and has
access to the variety of services within
the town
and the principle is therefore
considered acceptable
against the policies within the course
strategy and
local plan excuse me rose
it's council arsenal is there any chance
of getting that
larger than the new showing it on the
slide there please
um i think we go into the plan
as we progress through the slides
council i was born
yes it might be it's difficult to see
that one i do agree with you but i think
it's
it is shown in more detail as we go
through
yes it will be um the emerging
joint local plan um
extends the built up area boundary of
hadley
um just shown in the purple line here
with
areas earmarked for development here
here and here
our site is here outlined in yellow
so well within the built up area
boundary there
in terms of constraints our site is
here marked out in yellow the purple
area here is the conservation area
with listed buildings within this green
area up here is a special landscape area
with the blue are being flood zones
i'm not sure if you can see very well
but there are green dotted areas
which are tree protection orders
for a bit of context this is our site
here marked out in yellow
with green area to the east and
residential development
surrounding for some wider context
this is our site just here with
hadley high street running down here
the industrial area at the top here with
sudbury
to the west and ipswich to the east
this is the proposal and we've got
dwellings
along the northern boundary
leading round to the east open space
on the south with the access running
through the middle
this is the existing site with the
existing dwelling here
and out buildings there
and this is essentially what the layout
would look like on the site
the there will be three bedroom
bungalows
along the northern boundary leading
round to the east
as shown in purple there for you
two-story dwellings here and here
these would be two-bedroom two bedroom
here and these would be three bedroom
here
just run through the elevations with you
we've got two bungalows in these
locations
of the same design three bedroom
with the double gable at the front
and brick with hardy plank with plain
tiles
three more bungalows of the same design
in these locations
again three bedrooms with a double gable
at the front and an integral garage
same materials as the previous
nations again two bungalows of the same
design
three bedroom and of matching materials
and an integral garage
three more bungalows of the same design
here
in these locations a double gable to the
rear with
glazing and matching materials
as the previous this location we've got
three two-story
terrace properties
red brick
two of which would be three bedroom and
one
two bedroom on the end
this here are two semi-detached
two-story two-bedroom properties
one of which would have a frontage
facing out towards the road
and the other on the side
just could run through the parking with
you
four properties would have detached
garages
as shown in blue there and here are the
elevations of those
five properties would have integral
garages as shown in orange for you there
the 35 allocated spaces are shown in
yellow
and four visitor spaces which offers
approximately
3.2 spaces per dwelling
the access would be
located on the western side as it is
currently
with a 4.8 meter wide access way and 2.4
x
33 meter visibility display and i've
shown the edges of the visibility
display here for you
there would also be a 1.5 meter wide
foot way to run along the green
to allow pedestrians to cross the road
and link with the existing footwear
on the opposite side of the road to show
here for you so the footwear would come
along here at the front
allow pedestrians to cross and use this
footwear here
again i'll show you the footwear new
footwear here across the road
use this existing footwear on this side
so that they can access the services
within
the town
so again for you so the footway would be
along this
boundary here cross over and use this
existing footwear
on this side here
in terms of residential amenities the
bungalows along the northern
boundary leading round to the east
are not considered to cause any adverse
impact to residential amenity
due to the neighbouring properties being
set back from the boundary as you can
see
and the new dwellings being single story
concern has been raised regarding the
relationship between
these properties here and these
properties
this one at the front here there was a
concern about
light blocking and a lot of privacy
and then lots of privacy and overlooking
between these properties here
here you can see the existing bungalow
neighboring bungalow at the front here
in this location would be
a new dwelling this is the existing
bungalow on the site
the new dwelling would be a bungalow
appearing like this
originally the plans did show a
two-story dwelling in this location
but we have negotiated for it to be
changed to a bungalow
you can see that the windows along the
side of this
existing property here are already
partially obstructed by the boundary
treatments
and it appears that the majority of
natural light
for this neighboring property does come
through from
the front and rear of the properties
these are the neighboring properties to
the south
you can clearly see that these
neighboring properties are at an
elevated position
from the existing site there is
an approximate fall of 2.8 meters across
the site from
north to south with the two-story
dwellings being approximately in this
location
so there's not considered to be any
adverse potential for overlooking
and loss of privacy here
the concern was raised
in regard to um the impact to ecology on
the site
um the majority of the
mature trees and plant life would be
enhanced and maintained and ecology
assessments have been received
for this site
place services ecology were consulted
and raised no objection
subject to securing a proportion of
financial contribution towards visitor
management
measures at the store and orwell
estuaries as well as ecological
mitigation and enhancement
enhancement measures which have been
conditioned
a concern was also raised regarding
emergency vehicle access
it should be noted that this is a
building control consideration
however for the avoidance of doubt the
requirements are a hammerhead turning
point
with the dwellings set back which this
layout provides
the emergency vehicle would come in here
turn at the top and come back
down just for a bit of history context
in 2018 outline planning permission was
granted
for 15 dwellings on this site and this
is the scheme
that was approved at the time and this
is what we have now
i'll just take you back to what
was previously approved and what we have
now so this is a far more sympathetic
and more organized scheme to what we had
before
the section 106 would include a
contribution towards
affordable housing as advised by the
district valuer
following the submission of a viability
assessment due to abnormal costs on the
site the scheme would not be viable
while providing the affordable homes
therefore
a contribution some is agreed and it
would go towards affordable housing in
the district
i'll just take you through some site
photos here is the existing access with
the
road leading down towards the south
here is the existing access again with
the road
leading towards the north
this is the existing bungalow and access
here these are the properties
neighboring to the south this is where
the majority of the open space would be
with the two story dwellings appearing
at that bottom here
this is the existing dwelling
and existing outbuildings along the
northern boundary so this is where the
bungalows would follow in
the recommendation is for approval
subject to the completion
of a section 106 agreement thank you
thank you rose that's very good
um now members uh see if there's any
points that you want clarified by the
case
officer could i just start by asking
if you could go to um slide 30
um which you pointed out about
um once you get to it
and show you 30.
that's oh i must have got the wrong one
can you go down one more
no oh go go up sorry go up
try uh anyway you pointed out on
it might have been that one um that
there was some
um uh houses on the
around the boundary and the hedging was
rather low
and i was wondering whether there was
any landscaping to be put in at that
point
um i've also noted um number 32
to show if you could show me there where
which properties were affected
i would assume it must be to the top of
the picture in front of us
is that was that the area you refer to
now come right up with your mouse
right up a bit further uh
yeah i think it was somewhere around no
you've gone too far
somewhere around a little bit lower
somewhere around there
there was you show a picture of some
hedging and
uh there was the properties in the
background that you could see
and will there be any more landscaping
added into it
on the boundary treatments
[Music]
there are you on mute rose
if we lost her yeah she's on mute
sorry though just open this up again
yes so these would be new planting
across here at the top
these are all existing new planting down
here here
so is there any infill of landscaping on
the boundaries
only at the the northeast here at the
top and
at the south here just go through the
slowies upwards
i think we'll come to it then
this is the picture you're referring to
no okay
go one more
there that's it over the other picture
you can see these hoses quite clearly in
the photo on your
left hand side is there going to be any
infill of landscaping
yeah so along this southern boundary
here there will be some additional
planting
there will be that's fine then yeah that
was a lens and what i wanted you to show
me was where
on 32 where with what properties back on
to that
that's it where is that now so
the dwellings that you could see are
these ones here those ones there
yeah so they are at an elevated position
and these are the ones where we've had
um
complaints from the objectors
yes just in terms of loss of privacy and
overlooking but as you can see there is
some additional planting
going in here and here and
the this is a two story semi detached
two properties here so they are quite
set back from the boundary
and these are at an elevated position
thank you you've picked up my point then
thank you uh councillor parker you've
got a question
yeah thank you joe i'm just uh i mean
i'll save the main um
point really for debate i think but i
just just want clarification around the
affordable housing so
in the table papers um it says that it
was it was an admission so can i just
have
clarity what was it in a mission or was
this um representation that affordable
housing isn't going to be provided is
that was that a late representation can
can you just have clarity on that rose
but
but otherwise thank you help us i'll
take that chair
um so yes what happened was um
i was the original case officer i didn't
have the capacity i hand it down to rose
she's made a good job of it but one of
the elements was that a
viability assessment was done by the
applicant
it was then checked by the district
valuer and as reported on the table of
papers i
committed some was agreed um it was done
in the autumn i think it was october
from memory um and that didn't feed into
the committee report so that's that is
an officer error
um i should have seen to that basically
so that's why it's appeared
yesterday rather than two weeks earlier
um
so that is the position the the scheme
would not be viable
if the affordable housing were supplied
are you happy with that uh councillor
parker uh well
um it's an explanation chair we'll we'll
come back to it in debate but yes thank
you very much
thank you well i have the microphone uh
chair could i just um
uh verbally report the the town
council's comments which came in i think
um yes this morning because they are
relevant to that point may i report them
now
yep yep okay yeah okay so it's from the
the chair of the planning advisory
committee of hadley town council
good morning unfortunately because of
short notice the council did not
register to speak in time
to put its representation against this
application at your video meeting today
the council did not support this
application when it was considered by
the council for the reasons set out in
the report before you today you have
those comments
as you will see there were a number of
serious concerns about density footpath
routes
traffic issues and emergence and access
for emergency vehicles
um this is the relevant comment what
hadley council
did like provide for bungalows and 35
affordable housing both are much needed
and hadley
uh obviously the bungalows are still
there but we are particularly against
the removal of affordable housing
requirement
may ask these comments are considered at
your meeting today
and that's from the town council thank
you so counselor parker
that's most likely helped with you with
the answer to you and you'll
pick it up in debate thank you
thank you councillor osborne your
question
yeah thank you mr chairman uh yeah it's
just um
a clarification really uh on the
slides that uh rose has shown uh they
uh those houses look like they have
uh black window frames i'd take it i'm
talking about design here it might be
inappropriate at the moment but i would
think that that
makes that uh uh out of out of impact
impacts against the other houses which
are all white framed
you know i just want to make sure that
they're not going with that that with
that color
thank you rose
the color of the frames are gray
upvc
so they're not black yeah the the thing
is that
my point is that when you have these
darkened window frames
it makes the uh overall impression on it
very
dark and therefore it you know it
doesn't
doesn't look light if you like i mean
they are easy
yeah i think i can see what you mean but
they were told they're white uvtc
no it's great you said great you're
sorry yeah
is that correct rose yes gray upvcc
yeah i'd like to see them white because
it it does make a development like that
over overbearing in terms of it it looks
it looks
shocking quite candid with you i know
it's my
my personal look but if you look at the
whole development of 15 hours
the points been clarified you can bring
that up in debate
okay um counselor hinton
thank you mr chairman um just a couple
of quick points firstly
uh i missed out on the alteration which
showed that the
affordable housing wouldn't actually be
affordable housing but there will be a
commuted some instead
if that's the case why are they
proceeding with um
two-story dwellings in a mix of
bungalows and the second one point would
be
on page 24 of the original report it
talks about a small watercourse flows
along the entire south boundary and a
smaller stream flows along the north
boundary
with those two streams where does the
water go to
because we know anybody who knows that
area knows that the green is
underwater most of the time when it
rains and at the moment it is
and also connected to that why does the
footpath proposed footpath access
lead towards the main road rather than
where most of the traffic
foot traffic is probably likely to go
which is in the opposite direction
towards the school
i think there's three questions there
who's for clarification
uh okay so um just in terms of the water
course
i just get the plan up
so the watercourse runs around the back
here
around and down the south boundary
here
we have had consultation from the llf
a and no objection
has been received and subject to
drainage conditions which have been
imposed
sorry what was the um what was the other
question sorry
one one the second question as we're
keeping score
um the second question was why we've got
what two-story houses if we're not
talking about
them being affordable when they're
talking about bungalows for the other
other parts of the development
okay i suppose um that is just a um
design preference there from the from
the developers
and the the two-story dwellings
are the only ones that are providing uh
two bedrooms
here so and you can see them here and
here
the two-story properties
are a bit more sympathetic in this
location as it is a
lower point on lower ground here and so
i imagine that's the reasoning for
providing these as
the two-story properties you can and
development preference
yeah and the third point i've forgotten
now
why does the why is the emphasis on
footpath heading towards
lady lane rather than where most of the
traffic
along the green goes which of course is
back to the high school which is in the
opposite direction
okay bear with me just a second while i
grab that plan there
leading down towards the south here
there are no existing footpaths
um that would that lead into the town
the existing footpath runs towards the
north there
on the opposite side of the road so
by providing a small footpath
on the side of the green here the
pedestrians would be able to cross and
use this
however on the other side there are no
footpaths existing
and so it wouldn't be
possible for pedestrians to to access
down here safely
okay thank you um there's
no other hands up i think mark that's
the hand you've left up
um no other members want points of
clarification
no so we'll move on then um
we'll now go to the public speakers
which uh i don't think we have any for
this application
is that still correct um robert
that's still correct yeah thank you
so now um i will open the item up for
debate
so members uh councillor mccoy
would you like to start i apologize
chair i'm not certain whether this i
was expecting maybe to be able to ask
this question at an earlier point but i
think officers are the only people
present
who can answer it in the on the table
papers it was indicated that
the viability costs were approximately
five times larger than the commuted sum
this being the reason that the provision
of affordable housing was not possible
uh that figure seems i didn't know i
don't know if i'm allowed to quote what
those figures
are but the amount of money
coming forward in a commuted sum seems
to me rather small
and the amount of money in terms of the
viability cost
seems to me rather large and i wondered
if officers could comment on that i know
it's been
a valuation process but there was a
considerable disparity there
uh officers i think it's right that you
answer this before we actually go into
great debate
okay okay thank you chair
so i think the point i mean the general
point being raised is one of concern
about
why there's not much um sort of flesh on
the bones on the site
um and i think that obviously yeah the
district
valuer as a neutral expert concurred
more or less what they were saying and
there was a bit of going back and forth
but
the sum that you see on the um table
papers of 101 000 is what is deemed
to be a reasonable amount that's left
over when taking into account
viability of the scheme um to go towards
um
affordable housing um and the
figures quoted on
the on the table papers are the other
extraordinary costs on the site um i
mean typically drainage for example was
was more than had been thought etcetera
um and pilings needed because of the
nature of the soil etc things beyond my
ken basically
um but the conclusion was that that was
all that was left i mean i i don't know
if if council mccraw
needs some more information on that
point or whether that's accepted as as a
general explanation counselor
it appeared that the high existing use
value was also a factor
and some things were described as
abnormal costs i can see the
piling and the drainage has been
mentioned in in another counsellor's
comments
um but it just seemed half a million
pounds
seemed a rather large amount for such a
small site
um and where the social the housing
provision the affordable housing
provision
is clearly a factor involved in um
in meeting our policies i think that's a
point worth raising
fair point yep can you comment on that
mark
yes so um yes i mean i think i go back
to the
i mean the drainage you've had
discussions already this morning about
the
the various drainage ditches and streams
and and watercourses so
on the site that that's an unusual
circumstance for a
central urban site and that that kicks
the value up um
the high existing use value is because
it's uh it's a desirable
location it's in hadley um it's it's a
bungalow with a large garden
therefore as a site if it just sold off
for existing use it's quite an expensive
site
so that then has to feed into the um
into the analysis as well so that's why
things
then start getting expensive and that's
why there's then not a lot of money left
at the end of the day once you've
taken into account sil and things like
that as well that does seem rather like
having your cake and eating it if i
might comment
okay right we're now going to debate and
i've got councillor parker
thank you chair well i i mean i very
much take council macros points
um as as you know part of the debate and
that you know he's raised
absolutely the points that i was going
to raise on this i mean i just think
you know for one the um the applicant
isn't here to represent themselves so we
can't ask the applicant but i mean
there's a fairly obvious question here
is
surely the applicant will have known all
of this they must have known all of this
um before they put their application in
so it's no wonder that communities
um you know they're looking to us to uh
to to give a decision here but i mean
that decision has been thoroughly
undermined in my opinion
um by by the fact that an applicant has
come forward and his outline permission
he
you know made offers of affordable
housing and they're now not coming
forward
um i mean the the development per se i
don't have a problem with i think it
sort of fits within the area et cetera
and i agree with the officer's
recommendation but
um but i'm always just astonished the
application before us is for 15
dwellings five of which will be
affordable now that's been
um that's been counted by the you know
by the late very late table papers
um and i i don't really know that we've
got any
any legitimate um option other than to
support the officer's recommendation
here but i think it's a very poor show
frankly by the uh by the applicant so i
just wanted to make that point um
in in debate thank you yes i'm a little
disappointed that the applicant hasn't
turned up to
the meeting because there's often
questions members
uh think of and uh um he perhaps they
perhaps could have answered that and
might have helped
uh all of us out and yourself councillor
parker
uh right i've got councillor osborne
next followed by councillor jameson
now thank thank you mr chairman um yes i
i mean total agreement with that of
uh councillor parker and of council
mccraw
uh we we should be having affordable
housing
as per our policy he should have known
that before
he attained the site plus the fact that
um i'm afraid community sums to me has
never worked on certain applications i
i know of two that uh they were going to
put community sums because of the
viability problems
we never saw a penny of that so uh
and the legal uh thing we lost that on
on
on not coming forward with the legal
problems which
which is associated with that with that
type of commuted some
so yes i'm not i'm not happy with that
at all and i think that
uh again it's it's a question of he's
bought he's got the site
he knew what he was doing i would just
make comment although i
um i approve of of bungalows is that the
reason
because they've can only put the
bungalows down there or they've gone for
bungalows
that that is the reason why the i
understand what um
what our officer has said but um you
know that again
they always say uh the footprint of a
bungalow
does not meet the uh costs
in terms of of putting a house there
which would
wish they could get away with but uh i'm
sorry i
i just don't like the way that the uh
affordable housing have been has been
chipped out here and a so-called
commuted sum
of of less value and again we've got to
fight to get it
is on there i'm sorry i just don't like
that at all uh
mark can you help here um the commuter's
son
some less than perhaps what we were
expecting
and uh the difficulties in getting it
um can you comment on those particular
points and others yeah pennsylvania
yes the way it works is typically our
strategic housing team would try and um
allocate those monies which were
available to a
scheme nearby which may be relevant to
this development um having spoken to
the strategic housing officer and there
isn't necessarily one
very nearby but she did mention one or
two villages elsewhere in baber where it
could go
um in these situations the allocation
would be on a district-wide basis
so it would go into another to a an
existing scheme
um and and intuitively it's sort of
worth about one dwelling so
it could add that to it um but but while
i'm here chair i think that just
reviewing
what the members are saying and what we
have done occasionally is
is something called a viability review
clause
on the section 106 um to to claw back
excess profits
um if at the end of the development the
developers has turned over a tidy of the
sum
tidier some than they thought they were
going to then we would have a right to
ask for more i mean it would still be a
cash sun
it wouldn't be a unit but it would
there'd be more to go into the
district-wide pot
so the the recommendation could be thus
changed to refer to a viability review
clause in the 106.
council osborne did you want to come
back yes i would that is exactly what
our
my comment is that this clawback stuff
that comes in on commuted sums
has never worked we've lost we've lost
money baby has lost money on
on commuted sums on this clawback i i
can i can name the
i can name the applications where there
were a lot of
properties there and because the the
developer said he hadn't the viability
wasn't there he would we would have a
clawback it never worked
it never legally we did nothing about it
and we lost that money
so we're you know one property you know
i can't i can't understand why
while we're not imposing and making sure
that our policy of 35
affordable or the equivalent on that
particular site
is not adhered to thank you thank you
um i i just add the point about
bungalows
whether um residents and locals
uh don't want development on a site or
not
it does seem that it is more acceptable
when bungalows are offered as an
alternative
and um people do seem to uh
like them and accept them better so i
don't think
i'd like the message to go out
councillor i was born that um
you know because they've got to use a
bit more land to space out of bungalow
um
they should cram in houses so as to make
more money i don't think that would be
the message i'd want to see us send out
i absolutely agree with you mr chairman
thank you but the problem is
that they say that their viability goes
because
they're having to use bungalows i mean
you just got to look at previous
developers that have come
forward and made that comment they we we
don't do bungalows i think was one
uh comment company yes it was
and there you go thank you
um well uh councillor jameson followed
by councillor
uh mcclan okay thank you chair
um yeah i agree so far of everything
that's been said by the other
councillors regarding the affordable
housing if we reject this today
um this application can the applicant
fall back on the previously agreed
outline planning permission and if so
i must have not checked but was there
any affordable housing in that scheme
uh officers
i'll leave that to the case officer rose
do you have that information please uh
yes so they would be able to fall back
on the
outline and that was granted in 2018
with a three-year time limit to come in
with the reserve matters
and the previous scheme
does have an offering of five
affordables
um similar to what this scheme had
originally proposed
thank you councillor mclaren thank you
chair
um can i just really ask the question
that the loss of five affordable
houses in this in hadley how does that
impact the level of affordable housing
that
is that is at present or is proposed for
hadley
can you help rose
chair sorry is the question is the
council asking um
how many units are being provided at the
moment is that is that the question
we don't have that information but i can
ask okay well
mark it's um because there's a lot about
you know i live near hadley there's a
lot of development in
hadley and what i'm asking is
the seriousness of
losing five affordable housing in this
application
uh how is that going to impact what
hadley has
planned for the whole of the town
right so i think the question may be had
strategic housing relied on these
five units earlier in their calculations
is that is that sort of thing you're
asking
yes yeah okay what i'll do is i'll
message the strategic housing officer
and see
see what she says about i know she's not
happy about not getting the five i can
tell you that
uh but if you want some hard figures i
can try and get those as well
thank you mark thank you chair thank you
uh councillor parker oh sorry oh sorry
come to park i'd say councillor jameson
um
did i cut you off or have you just left
your hand
who are you talking to uh well sorry i
left the hand up
sorry uh uh while you're there
chair yeah uh regarding the
five proposed five affordable houses
that were
in the previous application would they
would the same scenario sit with those
would they still not would
they still not build those because of
the viability
if they fell back on the previously they
fell back to the
2018 application yeah um
can mark or rose can you help out if
they
uh would they have to lose the five
affordable houses if they fell back to
the
2018 um commission
well the 2018 one was outline only um
so some matters were reserved and i
don't know if rosa's got that
information about which matters were
reserved but i think the point is
uh outline you perhaps don't look at
things
sometimes as carefully as you would at
reserve matters so they've come to what
is actually a
a full application it's not the reserve
makes itself a separate full application
and they've looked at it um more
carefully
and they've realized the money's not
there so i suppose to answer your
question
when they came in for the reserve
matters relating to this outline
they would probably come up against the
same obstacle
right thank you thank you in fact if i
may share and i'll just come in
i'm not i'm speaking from memory and
general knowledge but if
if it was the case that the 2018
application had a section 106 agreement
that
committed obliged that the landowners
would give five affordable dwellings and
they would have to if they implement it
they'll have to either comply with that
or seek to persuade the council to
release them from the one of section 106
obligation
but we don't know whether there was a
106 obligation to i don't know
precisely 106 says but i just thought
that was worse
perhaps um mark rose you can find that
out while we're continuing
uh councillor parker yeah thank you
chair well actually
um um andy actually has just answered
the very thing because i think we
you know if we're not careful we're in
danger of going around in circles
because i think um
council jefferson is absolutely right
insofar as if we rely on the
on the outline planning permission well
they've still got to come forward with a
scheme in reserve matters and they've
clearly stated here that affordable
housing isn't isn't going to be
part of that scheme so so i suppose we
do need to know about that section 106
because i think that's going to be
material two members decision this
morning i think by the sounds of things
because
i i think we're as as much as i'm
disappointed that we're not going to see
affordable housing
on this site i'm not sure that that in
itself is going to be grounds enough
for us to um to refuse this application
and that and that for me is what
uh is what's so frustrating for me
because
you know members of the public are just
going to see
uh this whole lack of um provisional uh
sorry of affordable housing that's been
promised that the whole lack of it is
just seeing as undermining the process i
mean
you know say what you in on that basis
the applicant could just come forward
with with whatever they want only to
change that at reserve matters and
and therein lies the frustration so i do
think we need to know if that s106 is
is in place i think that's going to be
material but i would be
um as i said before i'll be minded to
um support the officer's recommendation
reluctantly on this it's not a proposal
no no um mark and rose um
can you answer that or do you need five
minutes to go away and find the answer
because we could take a
eight minute um comfort break and come
back at 10 30 if you need to find
this out well what is the question is
this question
about the 106. uh what
yeah yeah it's in place obviously
because the permission was granted so
the 106 is in place but yeah um
did you want what which details were you
after exactly members
uh the detail i think that uh councillor
parker was
asking for uh was regarding the uh
amount of
affordable housing whether that was a
condition or whether
he serves yep can i just yeah if i can
just clarify the situation so
from what into prey has told us if
there's a section 106 then uh then the
developer is obliged does he want to
provide those affordable housing
his only option therefore is to come
back to um to council and renegotiate
that 106. is that is that right um can
we ask the legal officer
um i'm yes i i'm i'm
chairman through youtube and i was
guessing and assuming that the 2018
commission had a section 106 agreement
that
committed the owner to provide the five
affordable dwellings
if that's the case that that would be
our standard practice so
as i think as if i may say so councilor
parker you you put it you said we'd be
going around in circles because
the the applicant has come for it well
to us for a different scheme that is is
now
we now have a request that the
affordable housing be solely provided by
as a means of a commuted son but yes if
um i mean i think i'd i dare say we can
probably
the officers can fairly quickly if we
find
on it'll be probably be on our public
website for the 2018 application the
section 106 if there is one will be
there quite easily to find
mark i believe that will be the case
where it is right mark
i think then um sorry
if members would like to know
particularly i'm sure we can find it in
a few minutes
yeah well if we take a 10-minute comfort
break that will give you
we'll come back then at 10 30 value and
um hopefully you'll have the answer with
that okay
so just um
[Music]
leave yourself movement and what have
you
welcome back members i'll ask the
um officer to do a roll call of members
see they're all present over to you
robert thank you chair
so councillor suez present councilman
barrett
present councillor beer present
councillor busby president councillor
hinton
britain council jameson present
councilman mccraw present councillor
mclaren
president councillor osborne president
council owen present and councillor
parker
present thank you chair we are all here
thank you um officers uh mark have you
managed to get the answer to councillor
parker's
um comments yes we have chair um
rose um are you okay to just read out
the relevant
parts of the 1906
uh yes i'll do that now um so the
section 106 for the previous application
in 2018
uh states that five dwellings are to be
provided on the site all of which
shall be rental dwellings and all five
of the affordable housing units
in positions to be agreed in writing by
the district council at reserve matters
the affordable housing units to consist
of
two one-bedroom two-person dwellings at
50 square meters
and three two-bedroom four-person
dwellings at 79 square meters
thank you uh mark did you wish to
comment
no yes yes jeff if i may
um so i mean obviously
rose has explained what the wording was
so that was the outline which was
granted in 2018
um it was then for them to submit a
reserve matters scheme
which could be looked at on its merits
but would still be tied to that 106.
um their option would have been to have
still gone with the 106 or
as we presume they would have had to
vary the 106 if they were saying that
um it didn't stack up and obviously i
would suggest that the choice to go for
a fresh
full application indicates that the
decision was made that the affordable
made it not payable
so that's why they've done it so one can
presume the likelihood of
a scheme coming forward with those five
would be very low
um so that's why they've made that
commercial decision
and our legal officer what is our legal
position on what you've
what you've just heard yes indeed i
don't need to add very much
i mean if the way the section 106
i've looked at it too in the break and
it's a standard as you would expect
um affordable housing section 106
agreement relating to a
development of this size if and the
legal effect is if they
obtained reserve matters and lawfully
commenced
that 2018 commission then immediately
the
obligation to deliver five affordable
houses in the locations set in reserve
matters would kick in and bind the land
so the only way to get out of that would
be to persuade the council to sign a
deed
a deed of variation or um extinguishment
releasing the
section 106 obligation and as mark says
if they
if it really is the case that it's not
viable to to deliver five affordable
houses out of 15
they're presuming the development will
not as a matter of practicality come
forward
under that permission or the alternative
is that
we if we were minded to go along with
this application that would
uh and of course they would prefer so
if this application stays granted of
course they would they would prefer to
i'm sure to um
implement that thank you parker
parker mark wishes to come back yep
sorry
because it relates to a thing you asked
before the break um i i've i've had some
correspondence with colleagues about the
the the state of things in affordable
housing delivery in hadley
um and my student colleagues
yeah mr mr vincent pierce has given me
quite a lot of information
about what's going on and there is quite
a lot coming forward um
of some of the schemes in hadley um he's
actually here to talk to you about that
if you want
uh but the picture is there's quite a
lot of affordable coming forward in
hadley
i'm gonna ask councillor mclaren if she
wished to
um to ask vincent price to to
comment and answer her query that she
had a bit earlier
um counselor mclaren
yeah would you like to hear counsellor
i'm sorry officer
uh vincent price's um comments on that
um i think it might be helpful i don't i
don't think i need to hear
mr pierce's comment but in fact that
confirms what i
i understood about hadley that there was
a lot of affordable housing coming on
stream so that has answered my question
thank you chair
oh right thank you thank you very much
then um
i don't think we need um officer
uh vincent price then thank you very
much unless anybody else really wanted
to hear from him
um kenzala parker yeah thank you chair i
i mean again really i think all that
we've highlighted here all
is is that an application has come
forward to us
and indeed a legal agreement has been uh
obtained
um that there will be an undertaking to
supply affordable housing and yet when
it's come to reserve matters we're not
getting that
uh and and i just i just wonder what
message that sends out share but
look we are where we are and i
understand um completely i understand
that the developers
um conundrum that they're in i mean you
know if there's expenses there's
expenses but it just seems
uh it just seems an odd way to go about
things to my to my mind but i'll tell
you what chair um
you know under the circumstances i think
the alternative that we're faced here
with
is is there's no development coming
forward and and actually the scheme to
me looks quite good so
um so subject to i mean mark russell
mentioned that we could condition
um the the you know we get an agreement
so that there is
you know we we at least get a share of
the excess profits
um over and above the commute
yeah over and about four hadley yeah
that's been commuting i see officer
marcus russell has got he's got his
finger in the air so i'm i'm ready to
make a proposal but i'll i'll listen to
what mark russell has to say
so yes i'll come back to you after march
mark thank you so yeah it was keen to
get in there before the uh before the
proposal just just so it's clear
so yeah the yes so just to confirm it
would be a clause within the
106 via viability review clause
without uh commuted monies if if the
profits were excessive
basically i'll leave the details to the
legal experts but that's that's the
sense of it
and the other thing to say chairs having
discussed the the scheme with
with rose during the break i think we've
overlooked just doing a pd removal
condition as well so if i could add that
into the offering as well
uh this is a pd removal for um
basically any additions to roofs that
that's that's the thing that we need to
keep an eye on
yeah so the take away uh permitted
development rights
yes i think that's very sensible um
kenzala parker
uh yeah chair well i mean i've just
noticed there's some other hands that
have gone up so
yeah indeed well i'll i'll listen to a
bit more of the debate than chairman in
that case but
i've taken mark russell's comments on
board
thank you thank you um councillor
jameson
uh thank you chair if as mark says
the applicant has realized they can't
put in the fight can't afford the
five affordable homes and that's why
they've submitted a whole new
application
but still quoted five affordable homes
in that new application knowing they
were never going to
fulfill that objective and then not to
turn up
today to actually answer questions i
think that's
a bit cynical a bit bit sad really
that's what i was going to say
i think i have to agree with you that
it's unfortunate the applicant
isn't here i'm very sorry to interrupt
we've just lost council mccraw so we're
just going to have to pause for a moment
i apologize for interrupting
no that's fine we won't make any
comments until we get councillor mccrory
back
so just heard from mandy that um he's
just rebooting his computer so it'll
just be a couple of moments
yeah if we just okay very quick
pause
and um they've got a comment on
permitted development rights that would
be addition
but i'll ask does to be counted in and
then i'll go to mark
one thing chair i have my hand raised
and there's a point i'd like to make
before a proposal is made
uh yes um i can't see your hand at the
moment but i'm sure it's there somewhere
but i'll bear you in mind
thank you just to confirm chair we are
now live
so we can continue welcome back members
uh
officers uh can you comment on the 106
information that you found out
because um one of our counselors um
computers went down
and he's now back with us and you just
need to refresh it for us
thank you yes um
uh chair could i just confirm whether
councillor mccraw heard the bit about
the
uh the 106 that's existing were the five
dwellings did he hear that i
did you were in the moment about about
to take legal advice on that point
uh but you had actually expressed your
point already
so it was the permitted family okay and
yeah
yeah and counselor uh sorry and mr
duprey confirmed that so so what you
heard from me and from rose about the
five units
that that stands as a piece of
information um if that's not clear
please let me know
um i then asked if i could speak before
a proposal was made
and that was to confirm that the
proposal should read as
per the recommendation with with the
following editions
um that the 106 should have a viability
review clause in it
so that we can claw back extra um
contributions to affordable housing if
there's excess profits
i also asked whether chair would
consider adding a condition to remove
permitted development rights
relating to additions to roofs so that
would include the new thing about the
two stories up
also dormers and windows in roofs
basically to
secure privacy so we'll we'll work that
condition but but that's the extra
condition
i'm clear on that just for the point of
view of determination and my ability to
be able to determine properly
i have that point and the addition of
the
removal of permitted development rights
a point i was going to raise later on
anyway so thank you very much for that
mark
uh i now believe chair that i'm fully
aware of all the arguments that have
been presented so far
and may continue within the meeting
thank you
right i'll go to the next speaker then
um
and i've got hands up from uh councillor
barrett followed by councillor osborne
and then yourself thank you councillor
barrett
thank you chair um i'm just uh wanted a
bit of clarity
on the um these sort of commuted sum
um because there's been a little bit of
a discussion about how it could get sort
of lost
um uh and not um uh bring about
um uh the the sort of intended um
uh what the intention is um can
can uh mr russell sort of explain
where that sum goes does that go
directly to buying a property within the
district that can be used for
um for the um relieving the the housing
uh situation yeah our strategic housing
officers will
identify a scheme that it'll go towards
right right thank you very much and that
could be anywhere in the district but
you try and keep it as near to headley
as possible so
if there were one right next door it
would go there they try and keep it as
close as possible but the reality is it
could be anywhere in the district
yeah but it cannot get lost or
not delivered no i mean no no they're
not gonna
oh okay i trust them implicitly not to
lose it
well just just one day sure
yeah thank you mr chairman it's just
getting back to the uh
the affordable properties uh coming
forward in hadley
but the question i'd like to ask is does
this
meet their uh does this meet in the need
of of uh hadley which hasn't been uh
talked about uh and incidentally uh
to that prior question uh of
of clawback it's unfortunate but
we have lost money on that there's no
doubt about that because they haven't
they didn't the legal
section did not uh make that point
uh to claw that back at the time and
that's why we lost it
and it could happen again yes so you're
not referring to
this application um right
uh officer mark can you help us on that
i
i seem to think that the claw back would
be
a condition that would put in um
if we were minded to go down the road
for proven and i think we were led to
believe
that the affordable houses in hadley
uh there there was quite a few
yeah available so the clawback issue
would be covered in the 106 in a clause
in the 106.
i don't know the circumstances the
council is referring to whether it was
talked about and didn't appear in the
106 or whether it was in the 106 and it
was never acted on i don't know
i mean it's fair to say that down the
years local authorities get stuff wrong
sometimes
but we're explicitly asking for this to
be a clause in the 106 and it will be in
the 106 and the monies will go to a
scheme in
in weber so that's what that's
meant to be all about um your other
question was about
um
yeah um i mean vince is still there but
but he's let me know about the
for example the persimmon scheme which
is um a joint local plan allocation
um for 500 and that is that's providing
35 percent
um so at the moment um
phase one is being built um and that's
35
of 171 so that's what's that that sort
of 60 odd you know
the next phase phase two for 273 units
that's 35
as well so again you got about 90 odd
there as well so
that they are coming on stream let's not
confuse ourselves we have
um we will have a 106 in for the
clawback
and um which would affect this
particular development
the question really wasn't answered the
amount of affordable housing coming
forward
in hagley i understand is substantial or
so i've been
so you've been telling us but does it
meet the need
does that amount of housing meet the
need of what is required at the moment
i don't have that answer to be honest
with you uh well
you know if you want the answers of that
then i would have to ask um
the officer um
[Music]
vincent pierce to answer it for us
are you there officer pierce
i am jim right can you keep it brief but
can you
answer that particular point um have we
well i suppose we always want more but
what is the situation in hadley with
affordable houses that are coming on
stream
please hedley as uh top of the
settlement hierarchy is being expected
to deliver more
affordable housing than it requires for
itself
it is being asked to provide
affordable housing to satisfy a
district-wide
need thank you
uh counselor osborne uh
uh you're you're happy with that i think
it was quite clear
yes it is you know we talk about need
against the
uh affordability streets coming forward
on stream
uh but you know uh we i mean we always
ask the question
does that warrant does that warrant a
need and if it does
and if it's turned down then then we've
gone against our own policies
and um you know i'm sorry but i don't
like the idea of this clawback it's
it's it's something that uh i know
uh has happened i i don't want to talk
about the development that was involved
with that
but they walked away from that scot-free
well i think the officers have got the
message and we'll make sure that
if we were minded to approve that we'll
have a um
claw back through a 106 agreement uh
i'll move on to councillor mcgraw
thank you chair um before any
recommendation sorry before any proposal
is made i just thought
i'd get out policy cs19 which i have in
front of me
the first sentence of cs19
requires the provision of 35
affordable housing the note
2 which is largely the second sentence
is not as in case here because that
deals with us
one or two dwellings and that does
describe the position for commuted sums
note 3 is on tenure mix and types and
the original proposal without the
late table paper proposing a commuted
sum
uh would be um appealed that but the
commuted sum definitely makes that
different
the final note which i assume is the
final paragraph sentence
uh says the onus is on developers to
provide
documentary evidence to support cases
where development viability is a proven
issue
and where such cases are accepted the
local planning authority will determine
enough etc etc and or
appropriate levels of commuted sums on a
site-by-site basis and i think the
question here must be
do we accept this evidence um as a local
planning authority
for determination and do we believe this
to be an appropriate level of a commuted
sum
on a site-by-site basis note 4 continues
at the bottom
sub-putting where this is justifiable
and supported by
up-to-date viability evidence and i
think those two points are at the key
of this uh its requirement
is it supported do we regard the
evidence
um as strong enough and is it up to date
well we we have viability officers and
that so
uh mark can you help us it is up to date
actually yes
um and it was checked over by the
district valuer just a few weeks ago so
it's it has ticked those boxes
i mean the complication is that it's
always a confidential assessment so
you know you can't be made a public
document but it's been checked by the
district valuer and they've concluded
um the reasonable amount of commuted sun
between them and we're proposing a
review
of this matter of viability
exactly towards the end um a claw back
um clause in in the 106 should
should more money be um got from the
site than is claiming to be the case
does any uh possibility of a review
prior to determination
exist well i mean not really because
they've only just done it recently and
we're here so
the only way we could do that would be
to not determine it and then come back
in six months or a year or
and i you know that that would be an
unjust thing to do to the applicant
and i presume they just appeal for
non-determination
it's regrettable perhaps mark that the
applicant isn't present because i would
have liked to have asked these questions
directly
absolutely that would have speeded the
process
um for our purposes um
yeah not much else one can say about
that is that
i think whatever the result of all this
i think the message should go out to the
applicant that though
their attendance was noted that they
weren't here
uh councillor busby you're next
thank you chad couple of points um the
valuer
is an independent valuer so it's not
done by the developer we've checked it
so we must take that as uh the right
figure it's like highway saying
something we have to take their views on
it
um to the commuted sums we
it does work we've got we've collected
over 2 million pounds in
commuted sums we allocated
some for eight houses in lebanon just
yesterday i think it was all the day
before so
it does work we do use the money and we
do build houses
with it i just wondered
this is a 1.3 hectare site which
using an average of what 25 which is
what we have
around in the district you'd probably be
looking at nearer
what 30 odd houses 32 houses so this is
only kind of half
its density there must be a reason for
that i would have thought
whether it's the difficulty of the site
if they're talking about putting pilings
in
and they've moved from two-story to
bungalows
then it could be a very difficult site
to cut bring forward
but one of the options would be that we
suggest that they could
put more houses in and therefore make
the site more viable
well as i have to remind you have to
deal with what's in front of us but your
point is noted
uh kenzala parker
yeah thank thanks chair so um
i i think i'm i'm gonna uh lodge a
proposal um chair if i can and because
um despite the um efficacy or otherwise
of the section 106 agreement we are
where we are at and um
i mean i will just comment um or reply
to one of the comments that officer mark
russell just said there that it would be
unjust to the
developer well nowhere near as unjust as
um saying you're going to deliver five
affordables and then not do it
that that's certainly unjust and to the
district as a whole and i think that
message needs to go out
loud and clear but notwithstanding any
of that
um on terms of pure planning merit um
we i think i think we would be up
against it if we were to do
you know if we were to pursue a refusal
on this so actually chair
i am going to move a proposal
that we um support the officer's
recommendation to approve this
development
um but i would like to include uh the
review clause
and and the removal of the pd rights uh
as part of
or in addition to the conditions that
are uh noted in the office's
recommendation chair
thank you very much the review then is
the
uh yeah uh do i have a seconder for that
canceler busby yeah you can put me down
as a seconder
thank you well your hand was up uh right
i've got cancelling
before we uh before i go to councillor
hinton
followed by council about could i just
ask i did mention to the
case officer briefing that the
electric vehicle charging points um
there didn't seem as though there was
any hair and i think you were gonna um
come back to us on this
rose um i i think that we perhaps should
insist on some uh electric vehicle
charging points
um okay can you comment at all i have
briefly discussed this with the
um applicant um and they're happy to
to provide that oh good so um
um parker would you add in um electric
vehicle charging points
they deliver freezing yes thank you and
your secondary councillor busby
yes chair i'd also like to ask something
about energy efficiency as well if
before we take the vote yeah um well
i'll take you now on that point as
you're the second
if you want to um
know what uh whether they're achieving
um
zero energy efficiency in terms of uh
solar panels or ground
right um rose can you help on that one
does councilor busby need to
ask for claws in it or is that picked up
already
because what he's saying and there are
no solar panels
um or any kind of renewable energy
um within the proposal so it may be
worth
adding a clause in about that but if it
was practical i suppose cancer busby
yeah i certainly think we should i mean
it's going to be one of the key things
for every building in the future so i
don't think we should let them off
no but you'll be reasonable but you'd
like a clause added in regarding
yeah if uh mark can suggest something in
terms of energy efficiency
for the housing mark can you help yeah
we we can just do a bullet point
standard condition
and to be agreed counsellor yeah
he's not being unreasonable but i think
what he's asking for
i should think they could adapt
something
yeah yeah right okay so they're like the
four conditions now we've got
um right i've got kenzler hinton next
followed by councillor barrett
thank you mr chairman well we seem to
have got a bit bogged down over the
affordable housing and whilst i agree
that it was an important issue and
should be sort of been sorted out
because the only thing that made the
whole proposal reasonably acceptable to
the locals seemed to be the fact that
there was a
30 uh affordable housing provision
within there
one of my concerns is much as anything
else is that the drainage issue has been
uh glossed over rather in terms of
anglian water and and the county council
in terms
they will be agreed later but with a
stream down both sides this site is
regularly
a a boggy mess not necessarily where the
bungalow is because that sits on top of
a slight rise
but behind it and the water drains
down to the green and often floods the
green
now we're talking about a footpath link
to be able to go
northwards towards lady lane but the
majority of traffic
a lot along there bearing in mind that
dead opposite the entrance to this is an
old people's home
heads towards the south and the high
school
and also the primary school so there is
a lot of foot traffic
heading southwards and yet we're going
to increase the amount of traffic along
there exponentially
by going from one but one uh bungalow
to 15 properties and
of course we're putting in a provision
for 39 parking spaces
so potentially the 39 to 40 vehicles
movements
coming into it as well so i think that
we've got to be a bit careful about um
how we uh assess this on by not getting
too bogged down with
just the affordable housing issue there
are certain
limitations on this site which are not
really being considered
all right um rose
or mark did you wish to comment
yeah i think the point is sorry sorry
rose you go good
sorry i was just going to say that we do
have a drainage strategy
and fra addendum and which have been
approved by the lfa
um and with conditions that
that have been imposed as well as
angling water raise no objection
um subject to a condition which has been
imposed
um yeah but if i could just say what is
the condition
because they get angling water regularly
put in
no objections but that's because they'd
see
another 100 houses being built somewhere
but no capacity issues
are brought into it at all and the water
pressure for existing
dwellings just drops away so i don't
trust the no comments or no objections
from anglian water
um well did they highlight anything
rose in there no objection
i'm just having a look at the uh
consultation response just now
okay so the condition that angling water
have recommended is that no hard
standing areas are to be constructed
until the works have been carried out in
accordance with the surface water
strategy that has been
submitted and approved unless otherwise
agreed in writing
um they haven't it sounds like they're
normal
yes it is um what they normally would
recommend we're linking that in mr
chairman with what the county council
responsible for and that is suds where
is the sud scheme for this site
where's the water going to be collected
for this site
mark rose can help
sorry there there is a there's a subtle
condition as well i believe
is there not if you look at the um it's
the eight one two three four five six
seventh condition there there is a suds
condition
so which is what but
very well saying that it'd be covered by
condition but we don't know what the
condition is
we're just left it is to be agreed
before
before they be before the schemes
developed basically
it's to be agreed up front so they can't
go and do the development before they've
satisfied the suds
um going through the local lead floods
authority
who we defer to on these matters so they
sort that out
after whether there's a position granted
after determination but before they
start their work
right thank you not
quite the way round forward but anyway
that's the procedure
uh counselor barrett
uh thank you chair um i'm going to uh
vote to approve
when when we go to the vote um
the bearing in mind all the discussion
but this does offer
us uh a higher proportion of bungalows
than we normally see and we're always
we're always asking developers to do
this and it's
often probably a viability issue that
they face
in in putting in bungalows they must be
more expensive
um so um i think there's quite a large
benefit that we see with this scheme
and it's actually quite nice that it's
not a very cramped site
um and that that allows uh proper
possibly i think a higher proportion of
parking than than sometimes we see
it's not all on the street it's um more
more uh accommodated in the the
driveways and so on so
i think it's quite quite a nice scheme
it's not too large
um it's not too near the boundary
treatments
it's got some screening it's it i
i don't have any problem with it and so
i'll be voting for it
thank you uh councilman mccror
on the councillor henson's question of
surface drainage
and hard standing areas um
is that securable in the long term in
the sense that
future residents have been known to pave
over uh
semi-permeable surfaces with impermeable
surfaces
um and that can significantly affect i
know from mature developments in my own
ward
where uh what was once in place has been
replaced and the it now becomes a
surface water management issue
uh i just this probably speaks more to
my ignorance than anything else
but i just asked that question mark you
look eager to answer it
what about ego but i will answer um yes
i
i hear what you're saying i mean that's
at the finer end of planning enforcement
basically um
did rose mentioned about the fact that
the they'd ask for no hard surfacing
um however she worded it anyway there'll
be a future
proof clause on that saying and shall
remain as such at all times
thank you for the future proofing i was
wanting to address mark thank you that
helps i will probably
reluctantly be voting in favor of the
proposal
thank you uh the last hand i've got up
is counselor ayers
thank you chair um i'd just like to say
that i would go with
melanie and and with um council macro
the thing that i do like is the fact
they're bungalows
and so it may be an adequate and good
um home for anyone who has a disability
or uses a wheelchair
so i'm taking it from that angle thank
you chair thank you
now uh is there any new hands up
counselor uh i can see
three hands up but you've all spoken
unless you just haven't put them down
man
barrett and hinton
no i'll take that then there's no one
else
has got hands up we've had a proposal
from um councillor parker
seconded by canceler osborne i think it
was
i didn't actually put the secondary down
no it wasn't counting there cancer busby
canceler busby that um we
accept the officer's recommendation uh
plus an additional uh taken away pd
rates putting in the clawback
clause electric charging points
and energy improvements
[Music]
so you're all clear now what you're
voting for
and i'll ask robert to take us through
to the electronic vote
thank you chair so if members could
please go to the modern.gov app
and go to the attendance and voting tab
by clicking the plus sign in the top
right
sorry i haven't started it yeah i
clicked the wrong button i'll be with
you in a moment sorry chair
yeah so in there you should see the text
of oh i think
my colleague mandy's just started she
got ahead of me so in there you'll see
the text
um obviously as well it's asking me to
log on
oh okay chair so um
i was gonna say you have to log in again
i'm afraid right
that's right yeah and then it's the plus
in the top right hand corner ah that's
the one yeah
class attendance photon
like that right um
right uh i've just got
up the um
uh oh i've got to scroll down because
yeah it'll be at the bottom of the range
yeah yeah
yeah all right
uh right i've got the blue box up
now i need to hit the photon tag don't i
uh yes so if you click the
light blue one then that should take you
into the vote
right in progress
uh i gotta take
that one and press close is it
uh no i've got to do it
guys that little bar on the side needs
to be made bigger because you need about
three hands
right confirm that's come up i think
i'm gonna uh confirm we're going in
has that happened it should have done
yep that's all come through now
all right so i can confirm the vote
chair um with
nine votes for and one against so that's
carried
thank you very much so that is approved
then members
so i think we're getting to the end of
the
agenda i'm just checking
uh just bear with me
all right uh yes so we've done the photo
our next meeting is on is scheduled for
wednesday the 13th of january
at 9 30. so i think all that leaves me
members
is to wish all of you a very happy
christmas
and a good new year and let's hope for
all of us and the public included
that next year will be a much better
year than the year that we're leaving
behind which i think we all want to get
out of very quickly
so very happy christmas to you all